c'est l'un des espions les plus connus
james bond est un personnage de fiction
découvert par le public
en 1953 son auteur c'est in fleming un
écrivain et ancien officier du
renseignement naval mais c'est vêtue
qu'un canadien originaire de winnipeg
serait l'une des inspirations pour créer
james bond
il s'agit de podium stephenson
podium stephenson est né à winnipeg en
j'entre dans l'armée lors de la première
guerre mondiale williams sera en
angleterre et devient pilote pour les
forces canadiennes
après la guerre il revient en amérique
et se marie avec héritière d'une
compagnie de tabac boulianne développant
suez est une méthode de transmission des
photos par ondes radio
il retourne en angleterre pour vendre
son produit c'est là qu'il devient ami
avec winston churchill député
conservateur à l'époque william
travaille dans plusieurs secteurs
industrie automobile aéronautique
sidérurgique et même le cinéma avec le
studio de films born in chains à londres
c'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un
bourreau de travail pour ces entreprises
williams a surtout besoin de fer et
d'acier mais l'allemagne a par la quasi
totalité des ressources molière
soupçonne que les allemands se préparent
pour la guerre churchill devient premier
ministre en 1940 ils veulent être des
états unis qui tarde à arriver
il envoie donc william stephenson a new
york la même année est en fait le
responsable de la coordination de la
sécurité britannique est le nom de code
de williams et l intrépide est rapide et
ça vous fait penser à quelqu'un
à new york le mandat de williams et
d'obtenir des munitions aux états unis
et de les envoyer en grande bretagne
bref pour liam est le lien entre
churchill et roosevelt
c'est environ à la même époque willems
et une seule forme le camp x aucun lien
avec les x men ici le camp x c'était une
école d'espionnage active durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était la première du genre en amérique
du nord elle se trouvait à whitby en
ontario ont formé canadiens américains
et britanniques à l'espionnage et aux
gadgets et une fleming je te rappelle
c'est l'auteur des livres james bond et
s'est lui aussi rendu au camp x et
l'histoire dit qu'il aurait échoué la
formation incapable de tuer un homme
lui-même et c'est plutôt tourné vers la
littérature et c'est d'annoncer libre
que ces personnages qu après la guerre
inflating guardian stephenson on défile
avoisinant jamais qu ils partagent
beaucoup d'histoires d'ensemble est
aussi des verres à martini
là on peut se demander quelle est
l'origine du fameux 007
certains y voient une inspiration de
l'audi numéro de matricule de l'armée de
william
bon ce n'est pas vraiment pareil mais on
enlève le premier set
58 et ça fait 0 0 7 on le rappelle c'est
une inspiration pas une copie toute
cette histoire sur le lien entre pong et
william
ça demeure une hypothèse chose certaine
en côtoyant l'espion proviennent
stephenson in fleming a eu droit à des
récits de premier plan pour s'inspirer
beau liam est un canadien qui a reçu
beaucoup d'honneur dans sa vie il a été
fait chevalier par le roi george vi et a
été fait compagnon de l'ordre du canada
en 1980 et au manitoba
on aime penser à williams f1 seulement
en se disant que james bond serait un
petit gars de winnipeg
[Musique]
oui